please welcome aunt midal talk about
fear because you're written a book about
fear
yes and you know what people fear the
most this I'm pretty scared talking to
an audience yep so many people fear that
can you understand that yeah I do
because where I came from my background
was completely in the shadows and not in
the limelight and I've literally
transferred into the limelight onstage
talking in front of thousands of people
writing books getting my name out there
you know just standing on a stage and
talking to people was the next fear that
I had from going to a war zone believe
it or not going from a war zone that
fear of getting through that door that
fear of not coming home to standing in
front of people and having to sort of
explain yourself and tell a story but we
all react differently to fear I wonder
if physically what's your physical
reaction to fear when I feel feet feel
fear is basically my body telling itself
to get ready and why I get excited about
that is because fear is your body
priming itself to step into the unknown
but do you get like sweaty hands and
I've been in situations where I've been
stuck to the ground my feet have
literally been I can't move and that was
you know at a doorway you know going
going to go into a doorway world
couldn't go into a doorway because of
bullets coming through the door and my
job was to get through that door and
I've been physically stuck to the ground
and when you physically stuck to the
ground like that it's obviously your
body working against itself your mind
saying one thing in your body's counter
reacting it so are you now there that
you actually enjoy fear you like it I
challenge it it's almost as if from it's
my body my mind saying why you got to do
this my body's saying no and I'm like
we're gonna we're gonna commit to this
and what fear how you sort of harness
fear is committing to it that's the
hardest bit that people get wrong they
feel fear and they go they go nowhere
near when they walk away from it but
once you commit to fear ultimately what
you're doing is you're committing to
your emotions you're committing to
yourself openly saying how would you do
that for example I say to people who are
scared of heights know this might be
stood near a cliff okay and they're fit
they're feeling scared and they get
carried away we've fixated on achieving
the objective whether you're abseiling
down a cliff or bungee jumping off of a
bridge I'm like get that out of your
head you know take those two footsteps
closer than you've ever been before I
said that you're exposing fear there
you're taking a layer off of it you're
getting closer and closer to the night
you're understanding more and more about
that emotion ie yourself but as it is it
also to to postpone fear
I mean if I were afraid of flying mm-hmm
I can be afraid for days right yeah
before flight yeah absolutely but but it
would it be with the trick be to
postpone that fear a lot of people drain
themselves psychologically and
physically days before because of fear
and of course you're not gonna get on a
plane of course you're not going to
achieve what you want to achieve you
know even if you were scared and you
went to the airport for example and
you've never been that close you've
never been in an airport that's why I
talk about that exposure next year you
might you might get to the airport go
through the customs whatever it may be
and get and actually see a plane and go
that's exposure again so you exfoli
exposing fear how do you how do you
react to I feel like I'm dreaming like I
feel like I've kind of left myself yeah
I understand that is like an out-of-body
experience probably cuz it's so
unpleasant that I can't be present for
me but have you ever been in a truly
dangerous situation yeah I had a really
horrible one with them a cyclist
who didn't like the way I was driving
and you know he got off his bike and
came to the door of my car and like I
mean I was frightened but I was also
angry it was a weird one time I mean I
find that if you have cyclists a cycle
up against your window just simply open
the door whenever you felt really afraid
for a reason very good reason this is
the this is so big for me because I just
met my my direct opposites I mean I did
we are I mean you say the other must
step into the fair I just wanted to run
away yeah run as hell and never come
back
but I remember once when I was really
scared then the greatest trauma it was
on my countryside where my is my s wanna
it started it to and the whole house was
some in flames they're like big big face
and the house was so near our the main
building and I had three III child that
there they were they were sleeping and I
just blacked out and I remember that I
called 911 and then I don't remember
anything except that I she kept on
saying the the girl in the phone I can't
understand a word you're saying I was
talking but she couldn't understand the
words they were coming out you were
speaking in tongues so my wife later
told me that she only heard me shout oh
my god oh my god
in fact one person he was trying to help
me something when you were by that door
and there were bullets yeah you're this
close of getting killed right yes I by
stuck to the ground there I didn't I
couldn't go through that door it wasn't
until one of my powers gave me a a boot
up he's like kind of paralyzed by how
nice yeah isn't that that paralyzation
that saved their life because have you
gone in there you would be shot right or
yeah well it's how I haven't thought
about it in in that extend justify why
the thing that I would do yeah and that
would be to run but could never paralyze
you again then well I died I was
paralyzed again with it on Everest yeah
because you weren't on Everest yeah yeah
well I when I don't have this well I am
I when I done Everest I found the first
bit of it quite easy to be fair so I
thought to myself and again police my
ego taking me a bit far into the danger
zone
and all of a sudden you know be careful
what you wish for
a storm came through and if one started
coming off the mountain I might you know
what we're gonna go up during the storm
and cameraman was like and maybe not a
good idea Mike shut up otherwise you get
sacked I'm not insane I said listen this
is a good opportunity to get up there
you know we will assess it we commit to
a certain certain stage and then we will
assess the situation and would commit
again again those small commitment
phrases and I can just remember being
stuck there I was on top of the Hillary
step in this storm about 80 90 kilometer
hour winds complete whiteout and the guy
that was negotiating a part of the
Hillary step had fallen off the mountain
he was on the rope two more people have
been blown off the ridge and I can just
remember looking at the situation I've
got a clear image in my head of the
situation
I remember thinking and you're not
getting off this mountain and then after
what after that thought process the next
fault process was you're dead and you
are dead and I could remember just a
sheer sense of panic again just engulfed
me I forced myself and his unclip and
jump off the mountain
now don't freeze up here don't be a
monument up here where everyone would
come through and go
I didn't want to be that but that she is
sense of panic and as I told myself that
I'm dead I remember just looking at my
toes my toes are wiggling and then I
said and the situation is telling you
that you're dead but you're still very
much alive boy so you keep on moving
until you don't know about it anymore
and when I told myself that I was alive
I actually wasn't dead the situation
might have been so overwhelming that it
was telling me that I was dead it gave
me this sense of euphoria of like wow in
this in this magnitude of negativity I
am still alive and ultimately that's
gave me the flame to to get off the
mountain and with all respect you you if
you didn't go up there you would also be
alive I mean being a soldier you do what
soldiers do but then why climb Everest
what's the reason I just wanted to stand
on another PDX of the world you know
it's um it's one of those where I've
learnt from it now you know I came home
to an ear bashing from my wife and again
it's one of those where you just you
know I've got to really rein it in and
some look what wife I've got beautiful
I've got beautiful children and I want
to be there for my children so that was
a rude awakening and I suppose it was
sort of chasing what's the next big best
thing to do I've done the mutiny on the
bounty the next thing was Everest but
now I'm right I underst you've earned
your stripes just this just chill out a
bit and maybe just come on scuffle and
every year and
[Applause]
do you protect your children from fear
no no I don't protect my children from
fear and it's not necessarily protecting
them from fear but I'm a strong believer
in you know you need to learn uh frou
pout for people to trip up on so they
know not where to trip next time right
but I don't believe in letting enough
rope out for people to hang themselves
you know that's that's irresponsible
but um you know I if I see that my child
wants to do something and they're gonna
sort of make a mistake then I let let
them go ahead and make that mistake
before we wrap up here
do you have something that's in a way
idiotic but still it scares you yeah I'm
scared of being an author and sitting on
stage with another war for that sold
forty million but hope you enjoyed the
clip for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe
you